we figured this is our first day for the
rich eisen show on raiders nation radio
9 20 a.m in vegas
we must have the man the legend
brent mossberger on the show and he's
kind enough to oblige how are you brent
musburger
hi rich welcome to raider nation in las
vegas
glad to have you on the best sports dial
in the city
i appreciate that and i am thrilled to
be had brent um
so let's get right into it super wild
card weekend the story of the weekend
uh is what in your estimation
there were so many of them uh each game
i think gave us a great story but i
think
let's take the overview is that the
national football league did an
excellent job when they expanded the
playoffs
and they brought us so much tremendous
entertainment
over a wild card weekend i mean i became
a couch potato
for two days and certainly we can talk
about winners and losers and each team
has got a story
but i think the overriding thing is it
was good for the fans rich and i think
that's
that's what you do you're in the
entertainment business and i think
the commissioner and the nfl office just
did a great job
and now you look forward to the
divisional weekend which i've always
thought was one of the most competitive
and most
entertaining and we've got four
tremendous games
uh looking ahead to so i just think the
nfl did a great job by expanding the
playoffs i think that's the headline
and then uh the the fact brent um out of
all of those games
uh that we've got teams that have waited
a very long time
to celebrate a win um have moved on um
and it's that's headlined one would say
by the goat tom brady how
do you think the bucks are fixed to try
and upset uh the saints this coming week
and move on and get one within one game
of becoming the first team to ever play
a game in their home stadium for the
super bowl how how do you see that
working
brent it's up to the bucks offensive
line
rich as far as i'm concerned if they
keep the pocket clean
that tom brady is throwing the ball like
he's 10 years younger
but we all know that at the age of 43
when you're being harassed by the
defensive front
it's very difficult to get your
receivers into play it just doesn't work
he's not like josh allen who can
quickly get to the outside and and find
a receiver downfield or run himself
tom brady's not a threat so the saints
are going to try to
keep him in that pocket and set sail
after him i think it comes down to that
because
brady's got wonderful targets throws a
beautiful ball still
and i think it will be the aggression of
that saints front
against the bucks offensive line that
will decide the game
and so um moving forward then
uh which defense do you think had its
the best weekend brent which one do you
think out of
all six winners has the best defense
that could
either overcome an offense that's points
challenged
or support an offense in a way that will
make them unbeatable
which one do you have there well first
of all i would say the rams
uh defense but we cannot look
past what was turned in last night
by the cleveland browns i'm not sure
where that came from
uh but right from the beginning somebody
had covered a lot down in florida one of
the pouncey twins
now he spilled that snap up over
roethlisberg's head and then
then ben and connor weren't too sure who
was going to try to jump on
it the one goes into the end zone and a
former safety of the raiders carl joseph
pounces on it
and and the browns were on their way and
they intercepted
roethlisberger four times now i know
that a couple of those passes
they were tipped and so they might have
fallen incomplete they weren't
really real clean interceptions but you
can't look past
the job that they did even when they
backed way off and gave roethlisberger
a lot of in front of him room to move
the ball down the field
they still came up big i thought when
they had to but if i had to pick a
defense
that's the best one left i would look at
the rams
i i thought that that was perhaps the
worst playoff game i've ever watched
russell wilson play
and i think all credit goes to the rams
and when we look at the front office
remember jaylen ramsey
he'd become a bit of a problem child uh
down in florida
and they gave up a lot of draft capital
they're getting but you've got a guy who
can shut down
an elite receiver and we all know what
that means
going to next saturday that's going to
be one of the great matchups
of the divisional is to watch ramsey go
up against
adams and the green bay packers it'll be
a tremendous duel
and the rams defense i guess the new
coordinator
we didn't see them in person this year
but as i understand that he changed some
of the principles that they were playing
by
they've made some trades and rams the
rams defense is the real deal
the all-time great brent mussberger
vision managing editor and also
voice of the las vegas raiders on
raiders nation radio 9
20 am right here on an affiliate of the
rich eisen show
um right here on a monday after super
wild card weekend
the team that can potentially threaten
the chiefs the most now that we know who
are the three other remaining teams
including the browns who see them first
and then the winner of the ravens and
titans who do you have as the team
that's most dangerous
for chief's team that you've seen front
and center twice uh
you could you could easily say the team
that's given the the chiefs the the
hardest time this year were the
raiders brent what do you got for me on
that front yeah exactly
uh well the one thing that you have to
do
you must do to beat the chiefs you've
got to have a ball
control offense you have got to keep
patrick mahomes
on the sideline that is your number one
approach
to beating the chiefs and to be honest
with you
i look at the baltimore ravens as the
biggest danger to them
uh they they have a very good running
game
that's no scoop with jackson obviously
but dobbins
if you get ingram back healthy they can
control a clock
a little bit and what they did yesterday
against derrick henry
can't be the same defense that you use
against the chiefs because
the chiefs are not going to try to run
the ball down your throat
as the titans do with with derrick henry
you need a different kind of a defense
against him
you've got to at least keep tyrek hill
in front of you as much as you can
and then you got to try to limit travis
kelsey nobody's going to be able to stop
him
but i would give the ravens rich the
best
chance going forward i'm not quite sold
on the bill's defense and
i just think that the browns played the
game of their life last night
and i'm not sure staying on the road
that they can come back with that
because
all you guys have to do because you've
talked about it is look at what coach
andy reid does coming off a buy
or a week off i think the chiefs are
going to be very very difficult to
handle
uh next sunday and i give the ravens a
very good chance
to go in and beat the bills so i i
would nominate the ravens as the biggest
threat in the afc
uh to the chief's reign brent before we
move to the national championship game
tonight and your two cents on that and
who you like who you don't like
uh news just broke during the first part
of our conversation
that doug peterson has been fired as the
coach of the philadelphia eagles
after all of that that being what we saw
with once this year and then
too much of whence before finally
turning to hertz and then not seeing
enough hurts
on sunday night football game 256 i'd
love your first blush reaction to the
news
that just a couple of years after the
philly special and the eagles winning
the super bowl
that this guy is out your two cents on
that
you know i thought late in the season
that they pretty much had stood in
support of coach peterson but i think
his handling of the of the quarterback
situation
probably infuriated the owner he
probably thought that once you make the
move
to jalen hurts and carson wins is an
active
that even though jalen was struggling
throwing the ball he had run
for a couple of touchdowns in that game
against washington
and i'm guessing that uh even the even
some of the philly fans came down on
coach
and remember when coach won the super
bowl he had frank wright in there
helping call plays
and some other assistants have moved on
and his
defensive coordinator schwartz has said
he's going to take a year off
so i think all of those things added up
i'm not completely shocked
a little bit surprised uh but all in all
not shocked rich and unbelievably brent
because he was hired on the the first
of uh of the year in 2020 before joe
judge and mike mccarthy got their jobs
with the giants
and the the cowboys respectively ron
rivera is now the most tenured head
coach in the nfc east with the
washington football team
brent that amazing how this how about
that it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable rich how that uh wheel
goes around and uh
gosh what what a great gentleman coach
rivera is battling cancer and
still making it to all the games and
standing on the sidelines
our class guy and the performance that
he got out of quarterback heineken
a full disclosure i'm gonna cover
college football for years and
follow it even to this day of course
i've never even heard of heineken
not a whole dominion okay so
and the little rascal played his heart
out uh made that diving touchdown
unbelievable and i guess if it shows
anything going to coach rivera
is when you want your backup or your
third string quarterback
don't look at the ballyhoot guys from
the big programs who goes six one six
four whatever
go look at those little rascals from the
small school that can move around a
little bit for you
and uh maybe that the scouts overlook uh
when it comes to the combine because
they're not invited
and so maybe those other guys who should
be the uh
third string quarterbacks around the nfl
this is the dulce tones the great brent
mossberger here on the rich eisen show
on the day
where the national championship will go
down and there will be a new college
football champion crown
uh from the ohio state university or
from alabama
who do you have how do you see this game
playing out tonight
you know uh rich if you go back and
clean the place
i love the crimson tide of alabama
they were plus 450 here in las vegas
uh meaning that if you put up 100 you
could win 450
and so a lot of my friends took a
position at that time
however i want to say that i haven't
seen a team
with a few games improve as much as i
thought ohio state improved now
coach sweeney at clemson of course fired
him up by ranking them
11th in the coaches poll so they they
had
you know they they want to take on
clemson and they beat him up pretty good
um tonight the crimson tide here in las
vegas are an eight point favorite
the biggest bet on the tide on a game to
game base has always been the first half
um they're a five point favorite in the
first half
the book is always shaded a little bit
because they know the popularity of that
bet and that's because
coach saban usually so far ahead doesn't
run the score up in the fourth quarter
and teams get what we call the back door
cover
i think it's going to be a very
competitive championship game
and it feels plays as well as he
can the buckeyes can push this into
the fourth quarter however no team
recruits nationally like alabama when i
was growing up rich
before your time the national team was
notre dame
eric barcegan went coast to coast
they had fans in california they had
fans in new jersey and he would recruit
the top prospects they were the only
school but now
since the explosion of television and
every team is seen week in and week out
coach saban knew that he could recruit
coast to coast
he's got players on that team tonight
from
all of the southern states but also
california pennsylvania kentucky
ohio they're a national power and i
i respect so much because the key to
winning college football
championships is recruiting and
no one no one recruits as well as
coach saban has done you got to remember
that before tua
went to the nfl and the dolphins this
year he still had a year of eligibility
he could be
the tide quarterback tonight that's how
well a couple years back they recruited
so i'm
i'm going to stick on the uh alabama
bandwagon
before i let you go brent what's the
worst beat you've had all year in
football
what's the worst beat you've suffered
[Laughter]
well you know it's always the most
recent rich and last night when pouncey
snapped that ball i had teased the
steelers
uh down to a pick em okay all i had to
do was win the game
and that was recovered for a touchdown
and at the end of the first 15 minutes
i was looking at a 28 to nothing deficit
i said to arlene
maybe i should lay this off at halftime
you know what i mean
my teaser went up in flames last night
but congratulations to baker mayfield
that uh
and the cleveland browns uh they deserve
it
they played very well and a little a
little memo to my
my buddy baker just keep turning that
baseball cap around buddy
no problem no problem there i bet i bet
and hey did you see
the uh the the shot on saturday night
of brady and george blanda next to each
other
at the same age and brady brady looking
like
they're not the same age you know right
lando was an old buddy of mine in
chicago
okay yeah and he was a hard-living
poker plan son of a gun there was nobody
who enjoyed the uh
the rush street night life any more than
george poland
i've spent many a night with him we just
both laughed because tom brady
looked 20 years younger than george okay
there was no doubt about it rich there
was no g there was no gb
16 wellness program he wasn't eating
avocado ice cream
back in the day no no he didn't
he wasn't into those for you couldn't
get george you couldn't get george even
to think about programs like that not
not my old buddy from chicago oh what a
great guy he was or whatever
what a great run he had playing
quarterback and kicking field goals down
in houston
later for the raiders oh he was amazing
george joyce hey brent thanks for the
time
uh i had to get you on after the one of
the biggest football weekends big
football night tonight college and
obviously now that we're on
uh raiders nation radio as a show you
were you were a no-brainer and i can't
thank you enough when uh
when you when you come on the show it's
a delight every time for me thank you
i love it thanks rich happy new year lad
talk to you soon
same to you that's brent musberger
everybody ah the best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here